in the last video we talked about the
idea that if i dug up a bone someplace
if i dug up a bone and if i were to
measure its carbon 14 and i found that
it had half of the carbon 14 that i
would expect to find in a living animal
or plant that i said hey maybe one half
life has gone by or roughly for carbon
14 one half-life is
5730 years so i said maybe it's 5730
years since this bone was part of a
living animal or it's roughly that old
now when i did that i made a pretty big
assumption and some of y'all have
touched on this
in the comments on on youtube on the
last video is how do i know that this
this estimate i made is based on the
assumption that the amount of carbon 14
in the atmosphere would have been
roughly constant from when this bone was
living to now and so the question is
what is the amount of carbon 14 in the
atmosphere and in the water and in
living plants and animals is it constant
and if it isn't constant how do you
calibrate your measurement so you can
actually figure out how much carbon 14
there is relative to living plants and
animals at that time and the way that
you can make that calibration because it
turns out it isn't perfectly constant
the way that you can make that
calibration there's two ways and i've
have pictures here of both of them one
is to look at tree rings
tree rings and i'm told that this will
work up to about 10 000 years
up to 10 000 years old i don't know of
any 10 000 year old trees i don't think
anyone does but maybe there's some
remains of old trees and you can look at
their tree rings and i think most of us
familiar with this idea that every year
that a tree grows it forms another layer
of bark and so you can look back to that
layer of bark adjust for the half-life
of of carbon 14
and then figure out how much carbon 14
was there in the atmosphere at that
period in time and so you'll it's kind
of a record of the atmosphere up to 10
000 years if you want to go even further
back you can look at cave deposits and
the fancy word for these cave deposits
are speleothems
speleothums
speleothems you might be familiar with
stalagmites those are those speleothums
that are kind of coming out of the
bottom of the cave or stalactites those
are the speleothems that are coming from
the top of the cave but the reason why
these are useful is these are formed by
calcium carbonate so they have carbon in
them and slowly over really tens of
thousands of years the water in the cave
deposits that calcium carbonate so it's
a record of the fraction of carbon 14 in
some of those years and you can go down
to resolutions of up to of as small as
10 years and so this will give us pretty
good estimates over tens of thousands
years up to 50 000 years and frankly
carbon 14 isn't even useful beyond
really 50 or 60 000 years so this gives
us a pretty good
pretty good
this gives us a good
record of carbon 14 in the atmosphere
assuming that it's fairly uniform
throughout the atmosphere and all
evidence suggests that and that that
that uniformity through the atmosphere
also goes into the water supply and into
living plants and animals now the other
thing and i looked into this a little
bit
it actually turns out because we are
spewing so much fossil fuel right now we
are
changing the amount or the proportion of
carbon 14 much much faster than it's
than than has happened in in other time
periods so uh just to answer the
question it's actually probably in the
last really the last 50 years where the
fossil fuel uses really exploded that
we've really been changing the
proportion of carbon 14 relative to the
other isotopes of carbon but anyway
hopefully that that
arrests some some of your worries about
uh the assumption that i made in the
last video about carbon 14 being
relatively constant there are there are
ways to look back at specific years and
figure out the relative amounts of
carbon 14. so it is a it is a pretty
pretty good way of estimating how old
living things are especially things that
are less than 50 000 years old